hello milkshakers and welcome to
metaphysical milkshake
yeah i'm uh i'm your host reza aslan and
i am your other host rain wilson you're
talking in a very dramatic way and i'm
going to guess that the reason you are
rain is that this episode
is the
season finale
of metaphysical
milkshake 170 episodes
is that right it felt like 170. no razza
i'm speaking in this way because i am a
professional voice-over artist
right and announcer and i speak formally
wherever i go
and i'm speaking as i age more and more
like a newscaster
and i speak as though kermit the frog
was about to join the uh aarp
that's that's kind of what i sound like
right can i also make a taliban joke a
little bit because of your middle
eastern
heritage or is that
our
audience already knows about you and
your racism
rain wilson i will say though on this
note
i was watching the 60 minutes interview
with zelinski the other night and that
whoever that 60 minutes guys get the
white hair they all have white hair but
the white hair especially white-haired
guy
like
i just wanted to shake him and be like i
mean he was a good interviewer a smart
guy but
like stop talking like that you don't
have to talk like a newscaster and be
like
so
here we are in the ukraine can you tell
me
why
is all this violence happening it's just
like dude have you never heard a podcast
before people aren't talking like that
anymore not not on our podcast that's
for sure so what are we talking about
it's you know this has been an
incredible year
reza i'm just you know what i've got
i've got the app open on my phone and
i'm scrolling through these incredible
conversations that we've had this year
my god i mean gabor mate dissected you
naomi klein
uh pete holmes made us laugh we just had
incredible conversations mayam bialik
made an amazing case
for religion i mean the list goes on and
on and on welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
tell me looking back on the year
what pops up for you where are you at
what are you thinking you know it it's
been a wild ride so we had a lot of
amazing guests a lot of
really deep uh topics that we explored
um and you know every once in a while
one of these topics would come up and it
would like land in a very personal way
and uh i got i got a list i got a list
of things
little guests episodes that i think
probably affected me more than others i
think they were all great they're all
like they're like my children i love
them all well i'm glad i'm glad you're
bringing that up because here's my
question you know we set out to have
these epic conversations about life's
biggest questions from a human
perspective we wanted some humor we
wanted heart
we wanted
intellect
philosophy psychology spirituality
sociology all the ologies uh in one big
kind of soup of ideas
but we also talked about when we were
setting out to do this that we wanted
the ideas to be relevant in some way to
to speak to us to move us
to help us in our lives to move us to
action so
did we succeed
in that at all i mean
or
was this just a bunch of like
pontificating and prevaricating or was
there anything that like touched you and
like
have you been made different in any way
are you different now a year later
since we started this season for cast
media yes
i think yeah i could say that with uh
with a good measure of confidence um wow
yeah i mean look uh so for instance i
think you you mentioned dr gabor mate
that was one of my favorite episodes one
of your favorite episodes i think one of
one of the better ones that we uh that
we did in our season one uh we talked
about addiction you know i think the
topic was are we addicted to everything
and the answer is yes we are uh but uh
as listeners know there was this kind of
really fun moment in the middle of that
uh episode when i was confidently
declaring that i am not addicted to
anything
i'm one of those fortunate few that has
no real addictions really except love
i'm addicted to love um
and uh might as well face it i am gonna
i am gonna face it
and of course
dr mate let me have it didn't he
an addiction is manifested in any
behavior that a person finds temporary
pleasure or relief in
and therefore craves
but then suffers negative consequences
as a result of and has trouble giving up
despite negative consequences but if i
give you that definition does there
being any belts for you personally
well yeah kind of i mean rain actually
uh at the at the start of this uh
accused me of being a workaholic
and
i guess that's true i am a workaholic i
have you know 14 jobs i have a lot of
kids that i have to feed so that's part
of it but uh but i never really thought
of that as a negative
thing you know
well the question is look at my
definition again the question is does it
have negative consequences on you
personally either physically or
emotionally or on your relationships
yes or no yeah that's the one i'll have
to think about a little bit more see
this is a really fascinating word
because i feel like my knowledge about
addiction really matches kind of um
society's changing knowledge right
like i would say most people i i used to
think addiction was just some kind of
moral failing right it's like if you're
addicted to something you've got a
problem and you should go and and and
fix it and then of course i understood
that that was a misunderstanding and
then i started reading articles that
kept saying no no addiction should be
thought of as a as a disease right it's
like any other disease that you have and
so you have to treat the disease and an
addiction is a disease and you can do
that through therapy or through
medication but what i find fascinating
is that
reading your material your argument is
that it's not a disease it's not a moral
failing it's not a personality trait
there may be some genetic quality to it
but it's not like a a thing where what
we hear all the time well if your dad's
an addict well then you're an addict uh
but that there's something deeper going
on something that does have to do with
with childhood right
well that's what i'm getting at so
that's that um
that's what i'm asking you like maybe
you're one of the few people that
doesn't have an addiction but again i'm
just asking that definition craving and
pleasure relief in the short term
negative consequences and difficulty
giving it up
was so insightful
he really drilled down on your
well your your workaholism and where
that comes from and that kind of
insatiable need to
continue to achieve i am a workaholic
i'm uh i admit that now
uh and it's not a joke either i mean you
know
gabor mate's whole thing is that all
addictions stem from some kind of
childhood trauma
and
you know what he made me realize is that
as you know a child of immigrants
my family came here i told the story
many many times with nothing you know we
were very wealthy in iran we lost
everything we came to america with
basically a suitcase each we all lived
in a one-room motel
uh in which you know my sister and i
weren't even allowed outdoors until
nightfall because the management didn't
know that there were kids in the room
um
my father went from being kind of an
entitled privileged
you know son of wealthy landowners to
having to work multiple jobs all of
which he hated uh in order to just
barely you know get by with the the
welfare cheese
and uh my mother worked for the first
time which was very it's unusual for her
generation
of of women did you have actual
government cheese did you get government
oh yeah oh yeah blocks of like gigantic
blocks of government cheese they kind of
heard the rumors of the government
cheese but it actually exists and you
they're the size of your refrigerator so
like there's nothing there's not room
for anything else in your fridge except
for this gigantic block of government
cheese
see i want to just say for the record
and i know i jumped into your story and
i want to hear your heartfelt immigrant
story um i've heard it a thousand times
but i'm happy to hear it again no but
seriously i love the idea of government
cheese
i mean this is a perfect way for a
government to subsidize
um its poorest citizens like don't be
feeding money to these mega farming
corporations just buy some cheese that
you give to the poorest among us as part
of the social safety net i'm sure the
cheese tastes like ass
do you remember the fact i don't
remember i honestly don't remember maybe
maybe because it tasted like ass i
blocked it out i don't know forget the
subsidies of of of companies um this is
a it's a great way to uh it's win-win
for the dairy farmers
and for the immigrants living in single
room hotel rooms in oklahoma keep going
well you know anyway the point is is
that like
and as as we were talking about in that
in that episode you know it really kind
of tore my family apart you know my my
mother and father
fought all the time over you know our
lack of money and resources and you know
it was a real strain in our in our
household and now i think about myself
as an adult
and
you know i'm proud of the fact that i
have like nine jobs i'm a full-time
professor and i'm a a writer and i
produce tv shows and i
do weird podcasts with you know strange
characters um and
i've always thought to myself like
that's hey that's something to be proud
of look at me i got like 15 balls in the
air and i think what that episode made
me realize is that no this is actually
a problem that i
truly am addicted to having
nine jobs and it's not something
necessarily to celebrate or be proud of
but it does definitely have to do with
this kind of buried
uh
kind of emotional
fear that i have
that
my family may not have enough that we
may not have enough that we may we may
end up with government cheese and if we
end up with government cheese then you
know jessica and i will start fighting
and the family will break down the way
that my family did and
and you know it was crazy that at almost
50 years old i had this incredible
insight that is that has profoundly
changed the way that i think about my
past and it's changed um the way that i
approach my work uh so thank you but
there's there's another element to that
there and and that is
the whole idea that you're that you
wanted to become a writer and for your
parents that's just an anomaly you know
to to persian parents like you are a
doctor an engineer a lawyer
you know those are your choices
and uh
you know you're being a writer so i
imagine that that
internalized was like well not only do i
need to succeed i need to triple succeed
to kind of prove
my worth and my standing as an
iranian-born
um
writer and that you know the the 12-step
parlance is like does this workaholism
did this workaholism uh make your life
unmanageable and uh
what's the answer there has it made your
life unmanageable
no but it has
had
a
negative effect you know on my
relationships my well-being my health
for sure
um but i guess i never really thought
about it in those terms because i i
never thought about it as like an issue
or a problem but it is it is it is an
issue and a problem
to that point i think i told this story
before in one of our many many episodes
but uh
i remember
it's clear as day the day that i told my
mother that i wanted to be a writer and
her response was
who's stopping you from writing
[Laughter]
you go be a doctor and then you write
nobody is stopping you from writing
and i was like no no i want to be a
writer like as a career and she's like
that's not a real thing
that's not an actual thing like yeah and
to this day by the way she still refers
to me as uh
as doctor
my son doctor dr reza and then you do
have a exactly you have a doctor like
nobody brings in ourselves exactly like
nobody asks what kind of doctor that's
that's her that's her hope
uh so that's what that's one uh thing
that i could think of that had a real
personal profound impact on me what
about you there's got to be something
you know so many of these conversations
i just loved and i was like wow they're
paying me to do this this is incredible
and then i looked at what i was actually
getting paid and it's like wait you're
paying me hundreds of dollars to do this
still
i don't i think the producers are
listening right now so i don't want to
say i'd do it for free but i kind of
would do it for free um
practically free
you know i would say that for me my very
favorite episode and this really says
something about our show was the one
that i did without you when you were
available yeah i just did you just do a
spit i just did a spit take for uh for
people not on youtube i'm so glad you
didn't tell your parents you wanted to
become an actor because that was the
worst spit take i've ever seen
you you know what they said in in when i
was studying comedy in acting school is
like you never have to bake a double
take
so
so
say like i'm looking over here
i'm not going to do a spit take but i'll
just do a double take for those watching
on youtube right now tell me um
say hey rayne the the pope is dead ready
go uh hey reign the uh pope is dead
wow that was
you have to commit to it wow
for can't have you can't half-ass it
yeah but
my favorite episode was my conversation
with my good friend david cho
um about creativity and pain and you
weren't there but and we were in the
studio which kind of gave us a license
to kind of go crazy i had no idea that
david joe was going to undertake the
persona of being me he knows a lot about
me and my personal life and he's really
into like
kind of doing deep dive therapy into the
essence of
you know what makes us tick and uh we
did a little bit of role-playing
it really um
echoed a lot of my story of how i felt
growing up
alienated isolated and how i
and how that manifested in so many
dysfunctional ways in my life and how
being an artist and and acting was such
a
a relief and an escape from from
how i could funnel all these emotions
that you just
openly
uh shared with me
how i put that into my art
so thank you for that why never thanks
thank you rain
i never would have
you know if this was five years ago and
i'd had those emotions
you know i don't know what i would have
done with them i would have taken them
out they would have come out come out
sideways in some way yeah i've i've
heard old uh you know
howard stern and yeah in your own
podcast that you used to do and it was
just
it sounded like uh uh
just someone that was in so much pain
yeah and didn't know how to deal with it
i remember listening to that and
thinking two things number one why is
this podcast so much better without me
and number two
why is david show a better rain wilson
than rayne wilson is
that that was weird
right wow so here's so what i'm taking
away is that we could get rid of you and
then replace me with david cho there you
go and david cho should have his own
podcast season two folks
that's what's coming up on season two
it's metaphysically it's all
possibilities but i really do admire
this about david and um
and it it challenged me in a lot of ways
and i love how
part of what we do reza what we've tried
to do
is walk this line of like we're not a
self-help podcast you know we're not a
huggy feel good
kind of oprah light
kind of podcast but at the same time
some of our conversations naturally go
in that direction because
when you're talking about psychology and
self-improvement and kind of
um
interacting in the world in a more
realized
way
then it it does tiptoe into and when
you're talking about addiction you know
it tiptoes into therapy and into
recovery and there are aspects of our
show
that have to do with improving ourselves
and i
i really liked that conversation with
david cho about
digging into
you know how pain and creativity are are
interlinked and it's kind of a cliche
we've seen all the
the movies of the tortured artists you
know i'm thinking about kirk douglas as
vincent van gogh and every other scene
from that was from lust for life from
the 60s and he every other scene was
like i'm so tortured and um
it's become kind of cliche but you know
how can you transform
pain into gold you know how can you
transform
trauma that a trauma that
causes us that leads us towards
addiction how can you use that to make
someone laugh or create something
beautiful um
and that was really uh
that was uh that was really cool i i was
really
pleased that we were able to to walk
that line so well some of our episodes
are a little could be a little cerebral
perhaps but i don't mind that sometimes
i like to listen to a nice cerebral
conversation and some of them are
kind of a little personal you know and
kind of get you on a gut level so i hope
dear listeners that we are satisfying
both of those needs
uh what i loved about that episode i
remember there were
well first because you know i mean i i
already i obviously know
about you know your story
growing up and you know the conflicts
with inside your family and stuff but it
was interesting to hear that coming out
of david cho's mouth that was that was
really interesting
uh
but then the the other thing and it
talked about like moments uh in this
season that have stayed with me
there was something that david said
that was so obvious
but it just blew my mind and it was you
know in the midst of this conversation
of like do you need
trauma you know suffering in order to be
an artist and his answer was like yes
because
everybody has trauma and suffering and
some of those people become artists
like it was so fast like we we're all
dealing with trauma from childhood like
we're all dealing with that so there's
nothing unusual about it it's not like
an artist has like some soul access to
trauma right like we're all dealing with
it it's just artists become artists and
people are like did you have trauma in
your childhood that made you such a
great artist and you're like well yes
because so did you
and that made you an interviewer and
that made you a carpenter and that made
you you know a housewife or whatever it
is uh i was like that's so
basic and yet so true and profound one
of my favorite moments
turns out everything you think you know
about probiotics may be wrong
i mean i don't know how much you
actually thought you knew about
probiotics but trust me it's wrong but
here's the good news seeds daily
synbiotic is the real deal not all
probiotics are created equal so what is
the daily synbiotic well it's a broad
spectrum two in one probiotic plus a
prebiotic
it's a proprietary formulation of 24
distinct probiotic strains in
scientifically studied dosages
proprietary engineered two in one
capsule that protects probiotics through
digestion to ensure delivery to the
colon because that's what it's about
folks
if you've taken a probiotic before and
you never felt a difference you know
what happened uh
maybe the good bacteria wasn't surviving
in your gi tract
seed is designed differently and that is
why it works
so what does the daily symbiotic do for
you it supports benefits in and beyond
the gut
seed will support ease of bloating
healthy regularity
colon and ease of evacuation
pooping but it will also support your
gut barrier i didn't know that was such
a thing skin health heart health and
micro nutrient synthesis
many see improvements in digestion
within 24 to 48 hours which can include
bowel movement regularity
pooping and eased bloating so start a
new healthy habit today visit seed.com
milkshake you can use the code milkshake
to redeem 20
off your first month of seeds daily
synbiotic that's seed.com
milkshake and remember use the code
milkshake
so warby parker
we've heard that name before it was
founded with a rebellious spirit and a
lofty goal to create boutique quality
eyewear at a revolutionary
price point offering eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lenses and even eye
exams
warby parker is committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores warby parker also carries a
variety of contact lens brands including
acuvue and biofinity you can save 15 on
your first order of contacts no promo
code needed warby parker also offers
their very own daily contact lens scout
by warby parker
scout
is a breathable an affordable daily
contact lens a 90-day pack is only 55
blue light filtering lenses are now
available
they're all the rage they filter more
blue light than their standard
polycarbonate or high index lenses
so it's super easy to get started
you take a home quiz you go on their
fabulous website
get to know their brands you can try on
glasses send them back
it's very very customer friendly folks
what a great brand warby parker is
committed to providing exceptional
vision care online and in stores
offering eyeglasses sunglasses eye exams
and contact lenses glasses start at only
95 dollars including prescription lenses
try warby parker's free home try on
program order five pairs of glasses to
try on at home for free for five days
there's no obligation to buy ships free
and includes a prepaid return shipping
label
so try five pair of glasses at home for
free at warbyparker.com
you guessed it milkshake
warbyparker.com
milkshake
and and segwaying there and continuing
in this mode of like self-help
self-improvement aspect of our show
i was so
really touched by our conversation with
the monks that's one of my very favorite
episodes from this last year we got to
speak to the
monks from plum village monastery
in france and they just mike dropped so
much wisdom
um it was
really mind-blowing and their
their kind of simplicity
humility and humor
were really
staggering but um i got to i got to rant
a little bit at the end
and
it's about a personal peeve of mine
about how
you know um
in so much contemporary
secular
self-help e
like los angeles
there's this idea that spirituality
which is a which is a topic and a theme
that i'm
super obsessed with and interested in
and writing a book about and i think
about a lot and meditate about a lot and
pray about a lot but that there's this
kind of narcissistic use of
um
uh
of spiritual tools
to simply make oneself feel better oh
i'm going to this yoga class or i'm
looking at this crystal or using this
meditation app and oh i've achieved a
certain level of serenity and that said
whew my job is done and then you detach
from it and go up go about your crazy
insane
non-spiritual life you know doing
whatever it is you do in the big city
and then you just come back in order to
kind of use it to stabilize and and i
loved how
the monks addressed that
how can you what would you say to people
in contemporary america around this this
issue of kind of almost a selfish use
of the mindfulness practice
simply to just
kind of make their lives a little bit
more tolerable sorry i'm a little bit
i have a little bit of bitterness and
anger around this because i i i find it
incredibly frustrating
maybe we wouldn't call that mindfulness
i think we would call that like kind of
panacea like we'd call it it's it's it's
something
[Music]
you're not trying to wake up
you're you're actually helping yourself
be a bit more comfortable a bit more
asleep
and just to get through the day and keep
it all going as is
so i think we wouldn't recognize that as
actually
what we call mindfulness which is a kind
of spiritual energy that helps you wake
up to see your life more clearly and to
see what's going on around you more
clearly and then when you see things
clearly the the ethical action the
motivation the intention the change is
automatically triggered and put in place
because as as brother was saying you see
the suffering you want to bring relief
you see the suffering of your colleagues
your family members you want to help
like there's this sort of dynamism in
real mindfulness which
is an awakening to suffering which leads
to a deep wish to
change and for action and movement
i think what was so brilliant about it
was that they the idea that
um
monasticism
like you go i always thought
you know the whole point of monasticism
was like to separate yourself from the
world so that you could go inward and i
loved when they were like well yes but
that's the means to an end you go inward
so that you could
go back to the world right you withdraw
from the world yes so that
you could re-enter the world as a new
person
and and and sort of act upon it right
which is i mean look it's one of our
favorite uh
motifs you hear it you know on multiple
episodes which is like
uh
putting your values into action putting
your
your you know uh morals into action like
what what's the point
of values if you don't act them out into
the world
and uh and it was just like a a
brilliant reminder of of that
foundational idea that we always talk
about and if if in spirituality in
particular that's a false spirituality
that it is um something to be used
almost like a drug to
relieve anxiety and stress just almost
in a similar way oh instead of taking a
xanax i'm going to do x y and z but
spirituality has to do
as well with well it has to do with the
spirit so it has to do with stuff that
has isn't of the animal and part of the
spirit is compassion and i love that
idea that that next step
first you have compassion for yourself
and then you have compassion for those
close to you and then you have
compassion for those that are alien and
different from you and then that
compassion and that need to alleviate
the suffering of yourself and those
close to you but then to alleviate the
suffering of those distant from you like
those are necessary spiritual steps and
i i have been thinking about that no
less than every single day since having
that conversation and i really feel like
it's my personal mission we
we steep ourselves in compassion so that
we can take action to reduce the
suffering of others and if you're not
engaged in that process then whatever it
is you're doing
is not spirituality
another favorite episode of mine was dr
ian wallace
um
he is the the dream expert dreamweaver
dreamweaver it was a straight it was a
strange episode it was like not like an
episode that we normally do it was very
much and we weren't sure what that was
going to be like going in right i mean
we had our doubts we're like who is this
guy we got sent this weird dream book i
was honestly i was honestly a little
skeptical this is going to be so
frou-frou but the dude was legit legit i
mean creepy legit
uh
and uh and uh
i got to share a
recurring dream that i have had all my
life and maybe we could uh listen to me
sharing that dream right now
this is a dream that i have had
all my life it's a recurring dream it i
have it
i don't know maybe
i'm gonna say maybe four or five times a
year
and it's a
it's a derivative of the teeth falling
out dream but it's not the teeth falling
out dream usually the way the dream
works is it it often begins with me
chewing gum so i'm chewing gum or
something
and then the gum gets stuck
in my molars like it gets stuck in my
molars and so i reach into my mouth and
i pulled the gum
but the gum has like this infinite
stretch ability and i'm just pulling and
i'm pulling and the more i pull the more
the molar it the molar never comes out
but it just it yanks and i could feel it
in my jaw it's the most
real sensation it's just yanking it and
yanking it and then and then so at some
point what happens is that the gum stops
being gum or usually like it a bit of it
comes out but there's still i can feel
with my tongue there's still a little
bit there like underneath the the tooth
and then i will reach in there and i'll
grab it and it's not so much gum as it
is just kind of like a
like a a fibrous material almost like um
almost like uh
like a tendon or something that i just
pull and i pull a little bit more and i
think i'll just pull just a little bit
more and it'll come out i can feel it
sort of
coming out of my gums
again the sensation is so real
uh even now as i'm talking about it i
can absolutely feel it and i just keep
going and going and i think if i just go
a little bit more i'll i'll cut it off
at the end i could like bite it off but
then there's a little piece still
missing there's a little piece still
sticking out so i so i keep pulling at
it i keep pulling at it
it is
maddening and it never
ever ends
what the hell is happening to me
ian what's happening to me yeah
this is the 54th most common dream from
around the world get out of here
no it's uh it's absolutely it's a as you
were saying that they weren't jerking
yeah yeah it's the is the 54th most
common one uh it can be chewing gum some
people will have treacle it's
interesting what happens is
some people just stay with chewing gum
uh people i often talk about some sort
of thread or some fibrous material
that's it which is what you share
i shared that dream that you just heard
uh with uh dr wallace asked him what it
meant like i said i've had the stream
all my life
and
what he said was i kind of i wrote it
down here he was like okay well so look
the the mouth
is how we
share our thoughts and emotions
and
he was saying what it what it
by the way he was like i think he's hit
that's like the 37th most common dream
the dream that i had like it's so weird
that he's just got that in his in his
head he's like that's number 37. he's an
encyclopedia walking encyclopedia of
dreams yeah and what he said was the
dream represents the fact that i
often have something that i
need to say some
some emotion that i need to express like
in my you know private
life and for one reason or another
i don't do so and it becomes sort of
the thing that i need to share is messy
it's sticky just like the gum right it's
sticky and uh and i don't uh and i don't
share it and
there's no reason why metaphysical
milkshake listeners should know this
about me but oh my god that was like
peering into my soul
like okay if you could if you could
listen in on any of our uh my me and my
wife's couple counseling sessions
that would basically oh i have
i
have as of course you have
then you know like uh this is a common
theme of like russia you need to
actually share the things that you are
thinking with your wife you can't just
keep keeping things inside of you
because they're too messy to bring up
um
i was like holy [ __ ] man this uh ian
wallace real deal real deal that was a
that was a very insightful moment uh for
me another moment that resonated for me
uh was
uh heather mcgee
and uh
her book what is the some of us right um
the book was so powerful and the
conversation with her was so
enlightening
because
uh so many light bulbs went off from me
about racism and her theory that if we
posit
fixing racism
on economic lines that just might get
through
to a lot of thick-skulled racist out
there
that there may be a solution ahead
trade public pool um
really stands in to help explain what
happened to a whole host of public goods
and protections
that the government used to really have
a strong commitment to in this country
think about the massive expansion of
working-class people being able to
afford a home because of subsidies and
housing think about social security
think about the gi bill which made
college free for a generation of gis and
all of that either explicitly or
implicitly excluded most black people
just like the pools and what i found was
that if you try to explain what happened
to the like great american dream the
great middle class the aussie and
harriet the you know it was basically
easy to have a really great standard of
living we have the highest standard of
living in the world and then what
happened starting in the late 70s and
80s where it suddenly became this
inequality economy right what an economy
that used to look like a football with a
fatter middle and and and smaller
numbers of high and low income people
then look like a bow tie with a shrunken
middle and a lot more poor people a lot
more very rich people like what happened
i know what happened in terms of you
know what would change in taxes and
labor but why
and really the drained pool helps
explain how it was
that the majority of white americans
turned their backs on the formula that
had created the middle class that had
given nice things to millions of people
in a public freeway and instead made
them a private cost and a private luxury
this was so imminently practical to kind
of like let's just break it down you
know like accountants you know if we
didn't have this rate if we invested in
the education and the infrastructure of
bipoc people of immigrants black
indigenous folks that
there could be incredible payoffs to our
gross national product and this would
lift everyone up it would lift all
businesses up and i know it sounds kind
of crass i mean it sounds
you know just kind of well you know
greedy and capitalistic but
maybe that's
we've we've tried so many other ways to
break through on this issue and and to
wrestle with this issue um and it's this
and it's a very similar parallel with
climate change by the way like
oftentimes when you address climate
change with the fact of like hey we're
gonna have to get off oil and gas anyway
and why do we want to be you know slave
to importing oil and gas from saudi
arabia and russia and places like that
why can't we you know generate renewable
reusable resources it's going to create
so many jobs it's going to you know it's
going to lift all boats and new
technologies this is going to be oh we
could be the worldwide exporter of
windmills and solar panels and you know
what have you um it's a very valid
argument to make to a big segment of the
population you know that electric cars
just make sense they're fun to drive
they're economical over the life of the
car and they also make our planet better
and our air cleaner this parallel
between climate change there is an
economic solution to climate change
rather and and an economic
uh way of viewing racism i thought was
really uh fascinating and exciting and
boy she backed it up with some hard
data and there was uh
a lot of like really cool
data and science around racism that i
had never seen before really opened some
doors yeah that was uh it was
fascinating it was
infuriating it was
one of those episodes that we do
sometimes like look we have episodes
that sometimes are very personal they
they really touch us make us think
differently about ourselves make us
change our behavior which i i really
appreciate then there are episodes that
are just kind of
mind expanding and pardon the pun but
that reminds me of uh annie murphy
paul's episode uh i think therefore i am
where
she explained
and you know it it sounds it sounds
sophisticated and complicated but but it
has these profound and interesting
implications she explained that
the mind
um does not exist
inside the brain right that the mind
is about the the conversation the
dialogue between the brain and the other
organs and the other systems or our
nervous system and that indeed um the
mind exists only
when the the brain encounters
other contexts right and other
uh people and brains and minds
and
you know that that all sounds very
scientific and you know hard to kind of
truly understand what it means what are
the real world implications of it but
what came out of that conversation was
this
fascinating new way of thinking about
the soul a subject that you and i have
no small amount of interest in because
as we discussed if the mind
and the soul are the same insofar as
they are both kind of the seat of our
essence right who we consciously are
yeah consciousness exactly right uh
awareness of self however you wanna to
put it
the idea that
the mind only exists in context
to other minds and and con
within the context of your surroundings
um
this idea that like
the mind is so much bigger and more
expansive than anything that is in our
body that it's beyond
our body
was i would say unintentionally
such a profound spiritual idea
from
a kind of raw scientific mind which is
uh what um andy murphy paul was that
that one was a that one was one that
made me think completely differently
gut instinct is a colloquial phrase that
reflects our sense that and it's an
accurate sense that um
the body is intimately involved in in
our thinking processes and and as i
mentioned there's this process called
intraoception which um
is
one of the ways in which the body alerts
us to all the things we know
on a non-conscious level but that you
know there's far too much information
that we encounter
uh every day in order
for us to consciously process and store
and remember all of that but we do
store and process and store that on a
non-conscious level so then
the question is how do we get access to
that information that we that we do
possess and the answer is that the it's
the body that alerts us to to
regularities um that we're seeing in in
um
in our environment to patterns that
we've encountered before it's the body
with those you know
little twinges and
feelings of tension or um excitement or
fear that are sort of tapping us on the
shoulder or tugging us on the sleeve and
saying pay attention you've seen this
before you know you you have the body is
preparing us to take on that challenge
but all of that happens below awareness
and so we don't count it as thinking but
it's actually um
really a very consequential part of
thinking we identify ourselves with our
conscious minds but so much of mental
activity happens below consciousness
you know listeners milkshakers we've had
so many incredible
guests um
a producer let us know during the break
it was 45.
it's 45 45 it feels like 450 is he right
about that yeah it felt like ten times
that many it was a lot of conversations
but
one of the things that we really loved
doing this first season was checking in
with you the listeners
and
bringing folks on the show getting to
know folks on social media having them
leave us some good reviews of course is
always super helpful and what we've done
for this episode is we've dipped the
dipstick in again to the pool of oily
listeners
and we are checking in with them all and
we would love to hear some of your
life's biggest questions
and address them
live on the air it's not live at all it
is pre-recorded on the podcast heavily
edited nonetheless we've got some really
cool funny interesting folks who left a
message at
slash speakpipe.com milkshake
speakpipe.com metaphysical milkshake
is the place to leave us your life's big
question
and let us connect with you auditorily
shall we roll some of these rez what do
you think let's do it hi i am luis
varela and i am a listener from
barcelona
um
i love how you
talk about subjects that are not usually
talked about and that a lot of us think
about
i am all for science here's my question
i'm all for science in a reality based
world a reality based world view
but
if according to quantum physics
the
basic foundations of our mass our
reality of matter
pop in and out of existence like
electrons
and other particles they are continually
continuously popping in and out of
existence can we really say
that this is reality what we see and
what we can measure
with our
science
and
isn't the fact
that
we have
especially now we can see how people see
reality so differently i'm talking
politically socially and even
scientifically some people
and we can call some some of this
pseudoscience but
they still have some sort of a crazy
idea of different realities
isn't that proof that reality
is really up for grabs and depends on
the point of view like quantum physics
says
very very i love this
i want him on the show can we get him on
the show please i love i love all our
global guests like we we've heard from
people from all over the world i love
that and including from barcelona i say
it in the correct way because i
am cool that way yeah i was wondering
why he didn't hit that the earth sound
though
what do you think what do you what do
you think about this i mean
he's talking about perception and
reality and science in the kind of
intersection yeah yeah i've thought
about this actually a lot which is a
weird thing to say but i have thought
about this
a lot in my free time when i'm just like
hanging around you know making dinner
and i start thinking to myself is uh
reality subjective
um
here's here's kind of where i land on
this like
there's no question
that
perception is subjective i think we all
understand that that
that our experience of reality the way
that we perceive reality is highly
subjective to the point where
one could make the argument that since
you know a tree that falls in the forest
doesn't make a sound unless someone is
there to hear it
then therefore
there is no such thing as objective
reality if if we can all agree
that perception is by definition
subjective
and that the only way reality is
experienced
is by perception
then can you make the jump and say
all reality is subjective there is no
such thing as objective reality
maybe
but i do think that one could say
that there is like an objective reality
out there there's an objective
universe a thing that actually exists
but each one of us
experiences
that objective reality
differently
that doesn't mean it doesn't exist like
you know it's the old what's the old
story about like the
whatever the the blind men touching
different parts elephants yeah yeah
you know
everyone is touching it differently and
so therefore everyone has a completely
different
understanding of what is before them a
subjective understanding
but there is an elephant
the elephant is objective
um and i think that's kind of how i
think of the universe
as the elephant
but that
there's no
i don't think
actually reaching that objective reality
there's no way that we could actually
experience it as objective reality
because
the very act of experiencing it
through our senses
makes it subjective
i didn't understand a word you said
[Laughter]
um
but it sounded good
i guess it sounded okay but um yeah you
know this is it's this is not my area of
expertise not my metier and and
definitely if we're doing a show called
metaphysical milkshake there is a
metaphysical element to
perception consciousness and the
intersection between
what can be proven in science so you're
saying you know if all reality is
subjective well a scientist would say
all reality is not subjective because
when we take a plate of iron and we put
it here and we have computers monitoring
it in cameras and data sensors and we
hit it with radons and we're able to
monitor what happens when the radons
bounce off of this plate there's we are
we are attempting to put together a
picture as twir of the reality
of you know what's happening that can be
proven again you could do the same
experiment in a thousand years from now
or you can do it in south africa or you
can do it on mars it doesn't matter
it's going to have the same result but i
think deeper than that
the thing that always freaks me out is
the idea of a chair like there's a chair
and you're looking at a chair and it's
brown because it's made out of wood so
that means
it's
some reason all the atoms and molecules
are absorbing all the different colors
except brown and brown is bouncing off
and hitting your eye so it's not brown
it's reflecting brown light for whatever
reason i don't understand how that works
it's not even a chair too it's but it's
not a chair then that's exactly what i'm
saying is yeah and then you go deeper
it's not a chair like what is the
chairness of a chair like is it um
we're taught that it's oh it's these
molecules that are all bound together
that make it solid but it's not solid at
all there's more space than there is
matter yeah there's way more space than
matter the matter in a chair could
probably be boiled down to the size of a
pea you know but
or even smaller like a bb but yet you
can sit on it um
and then is there there there's probably
more dark matter and dark energy in that
chair so
um
how we're seeing reality is this giant
illusion we're walking through this
giant you know uh
we are avid physical avatars walking
through this to quote
the james cameron movie we're physical
avatars walking through a matrix-like
environment that is
illusion upon illusion upon illusion and
it seems like the deeper the physicists
keep digging into what is reality they
kind of have no [ __ ] clue
so i don't know but thank you for thanks
for calling calling it in barcelona i
didn't get your name but thank you so
much hey guys i just started your
podcast and i'm very far behind
but i do have a question um i don't
follow any religion
per se
um i believe in the universe i believe
in
the law of attraction
um
all those
kinds of things anyway um i have two
kids and of course we don't go to church
any church at all
and i i was just wondering how can i
introduce them
to religion if i don't follow
a
religion like say my brother he's a
mormon
um
and i know that's gonna be something
that they're gonna ask me about you know
my kids
so i'm wondering
um how can i introduce religion to them
should i just take them to a church or
what would you guys recommend
thanks guys
i love this question
i love this question thank you so much
uh say hi to your brother the mormon and
here's the answer it's really simple
make up your own religion
and do this by stealing the best bits
from all of the world's religions
because when you look at every single
religious faith there are some really
really cool stuff out there and you can
just poach it and make it your own so
your
let your children grow up within a
united nations
of religions you know from hinduism you
can take the incredible stories of
heroism and the gods the beautiful
mythology but there are also some really
incredibly uh profound
spiritual truths at the center of it
about how we are all connected and all
consciousness is one
from buddhism you can learn those great
kind of
kind of eckhart totally boiled down
those essential lessons of buddhism
being in the moment
um you know the alleviation of suffering
from christianity we learn to like give
alms to the poor to follow in the
example of jesus christ there's
incredible stories about jesus that you
can read over and over again you can the
list goes on and on so just
assemble
uh a best of uh from the world's
religions and let your kids love and
appreciate all of the world's faiths and
what's beautiful about them all and uh
this is the this is the next step this
is the next step in the evolution what
do you think ros 100
i mean i'm muslim my wife is christian
and this is exactly how we raise our
kids we just teach them about all the
religions of the world and we do it in a
way that's fun and accessible you know
we tell the story of the buddha we've
had them make
little you know hindu gods out of clay
we've
done a lot of traveling we've done we've
gone to like buddhist temples and zen
temples we we actually created our own
zen garden
a little tiny zen garden in our yard um
you know we go to church uh we've we've
gone to temple on high holidays and we
just you know
there's a couple of things that that's
important about this number one
teaching your kids about religion is the
same as teaching your kids about culture
you know it's so funny that people like
a lot of very sophisticated and you know
intellectual progressive
uh parents out there are like i'm gonna
i want my kids to be global citizens i
want to teach them about the world well
religion is
one of if not the most important factors
in the cultures of the world and it's so
funny how like sometimes people are like
well i can't teach them about the
world's religions because i don't know
what if they become one of those things
number one
that that's that's really not in your
control you know honestly like no matter
how much you try to control uh what your
kids are going to end up believing
they're gonna do it on their own
regardless and number two and i never
get tired
of this fact and unfortunately i i don't
have the data in front of me but
the most likely indicator
for
why an individual
becomes a fundamentalist or i've
actually read this data joins a cult
is
uh if they grew up with an understanding
of world religions or not
in other words if you teach your kids
about the religions of the world
they are
extraordinarily unlikely
to become either a cult member or a
fundamentalist why because at a very
early age
they've learned that there's no such
thing as absolute truth that like what
judaism says sounds a lot like what
islam says and like what christians
believe sounds a lot like what you know
mormons believe and that hey there's not
that much separating you know buddhism
from hinduism and
when you kind of grow up with that
understanding then somebody shows up and
says let me tell you kid i've got access
to truth i got soul access to truth and
you got to believe it they're going
gonna be like [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here
they don't fall for it anymore so
i think for a lot of like secular minded
non-religious people who are like i
don't know i'm nervous about teaching my
kids about religion because i don't want
them to become like crazy religious if
you teach them about religions they
won't become crazy religious that's
fascinating i didn't know that that's
great that's cool to hear you know uh
it's very much in alignment with the
baha'i faith
um which certainly believes in the
universal truths of all the world's
religions and i want to recommend a book
called the family virtues guide
uh you can find it online family virtues
guide and there's a bunch there's family
virtues cards and there's various books
and books for teachers but one of the
universals that uh raising your kids in
this way uh helps with is the idea of
virtues because every religious faith
has the idea of like right and wrong
good and bad and it's based on virtues
and one might posit these virtues as
compassion and patience and kindness and
humility and these qualities which are
so
nobly kind of evidenced by some of the
great teachers like the buddha like
christ like muhammad that we emulate
these qualities of the divine and teach
them to our children because they're
certainly not learning them at school or
on television or on video games or on
social media so these
uh divine qualities can help our
children become better
human beings with stronger moral
convictions and not a morality of like a
judgmental morality of like
burning in hell right and wrong but
simply being a good person is based
foundationally
in the idea of
moral
spiritual virtues
good luck on your journey hi there um my
name's clara and my question is
are there more wheels or doors in the
world
thank you
thank you clara thanks for calling in
this isn't big internet meme have you
heard this reza i'm not cool enough to
to know what this is about are there
more wheels or doors
in the world
so
on the wheel side of things you can say
well cars each have four some cars have
two doors bicycles have wheels
planes have wheels
more wheels than doors trucks have a lot
of wheels very few doors but
then there's all the houses all of the
houses reza very few of them on wheels
but you know some of them are on wheels
yeah so i'm gonna go when i boil it all
down when i think about seven billion
people and i'm thinking about six and a
half billion of them
um live in houses without wheels
and
only there's only about a billion a
billion and a half cars on the planet
and vehicles like let's just say total
two billion when i'm doing the math i'm
going with doors i'm going all in on
doors so funny i
not being uh familiar with this meme i
thought this was a philosophical
question i was sitting here racking my
brain thinking to myself well like what
does wheels represent wheels represent
movement you know doors represent
entrances and no
no it's just one of those internet
questions but i would say yes i agree
with you i'm going to say doors
we're going with doors i hope someone
has done the actual research on this
after this has been bouncing around the
internet for the last couple of weeks
and uh dear producers if you can find an
answer for us on this we want to get to
the bottom thank you for this life's big
question about wheels and doors i would
like to know
some hard facts
let's roll the next audio tape
hi this is laura
i love this question
about
kind of our
big questions in life i think
the one that's biggest for me right now
and is weighing heavy on me is
not so much how we
deal with grief but how do we live with
grief and the effects of trauma
and
move through it and heal from it
i have a background in
psychology and i've had 20 years of
therapy
but it this is still one that i struggle
with so how do we
live with it in a way that it doesn't
completely
overtake us and shut us down
thank you again for everything love your
work love your podcast um and i'm
excited to hear your thoughts on this
thank you
yeah thank you so much for that great
question and you know
i think i've shared on the podcast
before my my father passed away about a
year and a half ago
and uh
during the making of this podcast
actually and
um
so grief has been a big part of my life
um over this last year and a half
especially that first six months after
he passed away
and
i was in therapy too and did a lot of
reading about grief and a lot of
consulting with other people that had
undergone it and meditating about it and
i i don't have any solution i don't have
any quick answers but i guess the couple
of things that a couple of perspectives
that i would offer
are number one that grief needs to be
honored and in our society we don't
really look at grief we don't deal with
death we don't deal with grief it's kind
of something to be
you know swept under the rug or shoved
into a closet and
grief is such a huge part of life um
we will all grieve
at some point in this world and it might
be for a pet might be for a dead fern
um and it could be definitely probably
will be loss of a friend or loved one a
family member
and
so it has to be honored and there has to
be a space given to it and an
understanding that grief is a natural
part of life death is a natural part of
life and grief grief that goes along
with it so
that's number one
um
and i think too that you know when the
buddha said that life is suffering um he
meant it that this is a life in which we
get attached to things and those things
are taken away from us and that causes
suffering in the sanskrit duka which is
uh irritation
and
uh
the more we understand it as a just a
natural part of the cycle of life then
it becomes okay
it's okay to grieve it's okay to be sad
it's gonna take a lot of time and it's
gonna take as long as it takes because
for some people the death of a spouse a
child a parent a loved one
um
is going to take a few months and some
people it's going to take a few years
and
guess what you never really get over it
you know i still
um on pretty much a weekly basis you
know remember my dad he was a dear
friend to me a supporter of me
um
we were very very close we had our ups
and downs like everyone does but
i still get sad and i still feel grief
and i have to kind of just stop
and honor it sometimes so
i'm sure there's more to be said on this
i'm no shrink but um reza what do you
think
i don't think i could add to anything
that you just said honestly
i think you said it beautifully you've
just witnessed history reza aslan has
nothing to add
unbelievable hello reza aslan and drayne
wilson this is your fan from russia my
name is olga
my today's big question is what is wrong
with the world and what is wrong with
people thank you very much
[Laughter]
olga from russia should we even be
answering this question reza there's
like 15 different ways to answer this
but like the 10-second way would be to
say
that
we
i think the the the simplest answer to
what's wrong with the world and what's
wrong with people is that
we
have this kind of narcissistic view of
the world in which like our experiences
are the only experiences that matter and
yeah we might be you know nominally
aware of other people um and their
emotions and their experiences but it's
so hard to
kind of
uh
be
what are you doing are you raising them
you're nailing it i'm celebrating
you're nailing it i love it it's so hard
for us to you know
forgive the cliche but like walk in
another person's shoes you know like
i'm i'm almost 50 years old and i'm only
now starting to get used to the idea of
sort of seeing a situation from someone
else's perspective and thinking to
myself huh you know it's possible that
they might be thinking something that i
don't think or they might be
experiencing this in a way that i'm not
experiencing it
um
it's just so hard to do it's so hard to
do we're just not we're not sort of
prepped
uh to do it and uh you know i mean if i
were to say like the the simplest answer
to what's wrong with everything
which should definitely be a season two
topic what's wrong with everything
um that's what i would say
you know you just were uh
hitting it on the head and we're so in
alignment on this question and i was
thinking you know what what humanity
needs more than anything else what's
that to go along with your answer we
need a compassion machine
an empathy compassion machine you need
to you plug yourself in
every day
and for 15 minutes it literally puts you
in another person's shoes
so
you get to be in the shoes of a
ukrainian family walking through the
winter snow and ice toward the polish
border
and you just see what the shoes feel
like
and your socks are wet
and you've worn the same pair of
underwear for four days in a row and
you've only eaten like a rotten potato
and and a snickers bar
and
um in your shivering and
you know and occasionally there's air
raid sirens going off and
you have to be in that person's body to
understand like the perils of war like
holy [ __ ]
war sucks
this is terrible and the same thing with
like an immigrant family
you know
having to leave honduras because they
ran a foul of like
corrupt government-supported gangs and
had to leave because their lives are
being threatened and they're trying to
make their way through mexico their
stuff is stolen along the way they're at
the border they just want to get jobs
and provide and be good citizens they're
just trying to escape and make a life
for themselves and this machine i don't
know how it works like it's a 3d it's
kind of looks like one of those oculus
facebook meta machines i guess but it's
got sensors all around you've got to
experience cold you've got to experience
pain
and
it's gonna put you into other people's
experiences and if everyone had to do
this 15 minutes a day
maybe
we change
the world
okay first of all i think you just
pitched your next tv
show and number two
yeah i mean or just
you know maybe you walk into the shoes
of the guy on the other side of the
donut counter
you know
like oh that guy yeah uh he's having his
own experience too and it's different
from the next experience that's good it
doesn't have to be an epic
tale of suffering it can just be
another person trying to get by these
are
all just like amazing questions and you
know maybe as we're kind of planning for
this season too we'll uh we'll borrow
some of these uh we got a lot
of amazing guests
so many more
existential questions to ask uh so many
uh just mind expanding conversations to
have uh
i'm really looking forward to doing a
bunch more of these with you uh it's
been a great season reza 45 guests so
many stimulating amazing conversations
i'm so privileged to be part of this
journey on this podcast
uplifting
exciting conversations
uh
and hey folks
do you want more of life's big questions
you can help us out find us on social
media please follow us at reza aslan and
i'm at rayne wilson of course
but on twitter follow us on at
metamilkpodcast
and on instagram at
metaphysicalmilkshake
that's at metaphysical milkshake on
instagram
let us know your life's big questions we
might just explore them on a future
episode and remember to follow rate and
review metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts and wherever else you listen to
podcasts and
what else res well you can also
subscribe to the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel people
you can watch our full episodes
every
week rain i'll see you next season
i'll see you next season same podcast
channel
new season metaphysical milkshake thanks
to all of our producers and friends at
cast media
and uh
so excited and thanks to all of you and
thank you all of you you dear beautiful
wonderful smart brilliant big hearted
milkshakers thanks for coming along this
ride with us
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i just feel like that's the the most
russian question i've ever heard in my
entire life like what's wrong with the
world what's wrong with people it's like
out of a check-off i was just gonna say
i'm pretty sure that's like the title of
the dostoevsky novel am i wrong am i
wrong what's wrong with the world what's
wrong with what's wrong with the world
what's wrong with people
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you